[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast livestream our 23rd 23rd time
once again Wow again prime that does
feel that feels alright I'm sitting with
dr. Heather hi as always and we are
facing so many very heavy topics that we
are going to try to grapple with
together last time we started what I
think is a very healthy tradition in
light of how things are going in 2020
where instead of diving right into the
ultra timely ultra heavy material we
start with something amusing a joke an
anecdote something just to set the mood
so that we all feel okay so with that
the floor is yours
great thank you so much that's hilarious
so folks actually this has been a lesson
on a different topic the lesson is
married as much as it gets a bad rap
people say it's just a piece of paper
why do I need the government to sanction
my relationship marriage is a marvelous
thing and among its best features or it
makes it really complicated and
expensive for someone to leave you this
is truly presumably also so expensive
yeah I haven't checked but that's what
I've heard yeah but just sort of
thinking through all the steps that be
required
let's just put it this way Heather
however expensive you have heard
divorces I think it's way worse than
that sure it's this is fabulous great
alright so we do have a lot going on we
have good Lord okay it's it's only noon
thirty where we are there's been no
alcohol or drugs of any sort for a very
long time I saw where somebody could
have drugged this yeah we don't it would
have had to have been one of our
children or our animals I mean I
wouldn't put it past any of them okay
okay so we have things going on we have
an autonomous zone having been declared
in the center of Seattle which I would
say would be absolutely
beyond belief if we hadn't already seen
this block and a half from our own home
at Evergreen in 2017 so that's going on
we have a shooting that has just taken
place in Atlanta that is suddenly
trending on Twitter there's all sorts of
things that need to be discussed and
carefully and of course there's never
any time to parse these things and
figure out how to get into them in a way
that everybody can get their footing so
anyway I think you have a sense of where
we might we might begin with that
material here well actually what I have
what I've written up but I want to start
by showing us and I've written up isn't
directly about either of those things
but it obviously speaks to the current
moment so I think we're gonna start by
showing a video that you would point it
out to me it's a bit over two minutes
long and and then I have a little
monologue and then we'll launch into
everything else so Zack if you want to
show the first video I am NOT your enemy
you are not my enemy yet this land no
matter what but in the day no matter
what I'm here for you okay
[Music]
understand all right so that video is
one of a couple very much like it that
we have now seen and before you get to
your comments about it I just want to
put a placeholder here and say I not
only want to talk about what that video
means but I want to talk about what role
it is or isn't playing in our discussion
of the current moment so we'll return to
that later all right all right
so in this video we have people clearly
using their First Amendment rights and
the the response that I had that Brett
had is why are they stopped what is
going on what is that and once again I
want to remind us of the First Amendment
as I did a couple of episodes ago and 20
it reads quote Congress shall make no
law respecting us
- wind of religion or prohibiting the
free exercise thereof or abridging the
freedom of speech or of the press or the
right of the people peaceably to
assemble and to petition the government
for a redress of grievances not only is
speech explicitly protected in this
beautiful sentence that moves us from
the most private thing the thoughts in
our own head to the most public but so
too is peaceful assembly amputation of
the government for redress of grievances
one could argue I believe that these
peaceful protesters patently peaceful
protesters that am and that in
particular the man who was speaking in
the last clip was making an appeal to
the government or at least agents of the
government and he is asking for redress
that his resolution in the form of
asking for understanding he's asking
that we treat one another as human
beings
why was he hauled off what pasta what
possible justification could there be I
see none it's all a return to that that
is one abomination that is happening now
here is another one no less important
but harder for most to grapple with the
mayor of Boston sign had promoted an
executive order yesterday On June 12th
2020 declaring among other things that
quote whereas the COBIT 19 pandemic has
revealed reaffirmed and cast in sharp
relief the emergency nature of these
preexisting inequity is caused by
systemic racism in cases where race and
ethnicity are known the rate of reported
Koba 19 cases for black Boston residents
is two hundred sixty eight point eight
per 10,000 compared with two hundred
thirteen point two per 10,000 for Latin
X Hispanic residents and eighty nine
point eight for ten countdown for ten
thousand for white residents end quote
so let me begin by pointing out that the
numbers cited in the executive order
from the mayor of Boston looks stark but
not just for black people they also
looks dark for Latino people and yet
we're not as a nation focused on Latino
people that is not apparently the moment
this is not apparently the moment for
Latino people to speak or to expect a
redress of grievances it is also true
that the numbers absent absent
statistical analysis which would be
simple to do if you had the actual data
are insufficient to claim unequal
outcomes although I grant that at first
glance it certainly appears that blacks
and Latinos in Boston are suffering
unequal outcomes compared to whites and
we know that that conclusion is borne
out by actual analysis
from other places there is racial
disparity in health outcomes regarding
co19
but then of course it is also true that
there are sexist parity in health
outcomes regarding co19 more men than
women die of this disease and we don't
see the equivalent hypothesis that sex
disparities in komen 19 are due to
historic and systemic misandry
why well in part because the idea that
dissonant effects of kovat 19 on men is
due to mis Andrea's patently ludicrous
there has been abundant historic sexism
just as there has been abundant historic
racism and not primarily against manner
against white people but I posit that we
also don't hear that hypothesis nor are
we seeing differential outcomes by sex
focused on right now because it doesn't
conform to one of our currently
sanctioned narratives consider that if
women were suffering from Koba 19 at
higher rates than men we likely would be
hearing that it was due to sexism and
not as one hypothesis but as the answer
the problem with compelled speech then
should be obvious especially with the
First Amendment still shining at us
beacon like across the centuries but as
Orwell illustrated in 1984 the power and
compelling speech is that in time
thought is compelled as well those who
want to compel what you think may well
start by compelling what you say this in
a nutshell is the problem with compelled
speech if we are all required to shout
and proclaim hashtag black lives matter
at all times meaning that we are
constantly focused on race as the
explanatory factor in society and
similarly if we are told constantly that
all divergent outcomes between men and
women in which women come out behind use
due to sexism we have arrived too
compelled thought humans I believe have
inherently scientific minds which means
that we can propose multiple
explanations for an observed phenomenon
and try to distinguish between those
explanations all children do this many
children have this intuitive scientific
tinkering drilled out of them in school
and by authority figures of all kinds
looking for what is actually going on
takes time it's messy and it will offend
many of those who have arrived at the
collusion that they themselves like they
will try to stop the investigation they
may even try to tell you that it is
racist to investigate
compelled speech restrict scientific
tendencies and so leads to compelled
thought if the Overton Window has shrunk
so far that an observation of a pattern
has only one allowable explanation then
we have neither freedom of speech nor of
thought and we have abandoned science if
the Overton Window has shrunk so far
that an observation of a pattern such as
disparities and health outcomes between
black and white people with regard to Co
vat19 has only one allowable explanation
historic and systemic racism then not
only do we have neither freedom of
speech nor freedom of thought but we
also a little chance of actually
figuring out what is going on we also
have little ant chance of actually
fixing the problem unless the one
officially sanctioned explanation
happens to be fully explanatory for all
observed patterns in all cases I can
guarantee that racism is not the only
explanation for racial disparities and
health outcomes I can also guarantee
that racism is insufficiently precise to
be actionable and this in part is the
goal of the activists it is presumably
not the goal of the mayor of Boston I
want to believe that he is trying to do
good and to do right by his people but
having a single vague explanation that
can be wielded like a cudgel to
simultaneously silence dissent and which
cannot be operationalized that is the
route to totalitarianism it is also as
James Lindsay has described very much
like the argument that any natural
phenomenon which cannot currently be
explained by science must only be
explicable by God this is known as the
God of the gaps God fills in where
science can't todays activism has
created a racism of the gaps
racism fills in as the go-to explanation
whenever any other explanation isn't
immediately obvious and sometimes even
when it is James Lindsey again on
Twitter today said this racism of the
gaps is an allusion to the God of the
gaps argument where many people will say
the explanation for some unknown
phenomenon how did life start must be
gone it's a bad argument a filler why is
there disparity must be systemic racism
what else could it be so systemic racism
is usually a way to say that complicated
and unknown or inconvenient and
suppressed reasons for differences in
outcome
must be racism in the vaguest sense we
see a difference James right don't need
to find out real reasons and that must
be racism it's fraudulent and culty he
finishes
I would say if we really want to be able
to address grievances and make the world
is honorable equal and fair for everyone
as possible we can't have compelled
speech and we can't have compelled
thought racism of the gaps must stop
just a sec some sexism of the gaps must
stop racism in particular and more
precisely contemporary effects of
historical racism is very likely an
explanation for many observed
inequalities and even a primary one in
some cases but if we're not allowed to
consider alternative hypotheses then we
are doomed we will not be allowed to
discover what is true and we will be
buried in confusion and chaos
finally this week a UC Berkeley
professor who remains anonymous sends a
scathing letter to some of his
colleagues decry the compelled speech
taking over academia in the world he is
himself a person of color his eye daddy
has been confirmed but not made public
by one of the people who received the
letter and he too finds the cry of
racism to explain every single
difference in outcome between races a
dishonest and untrue conclusion he
cannot stand that people who call
themselves scholars and electoral czar
falling in line neither can i we have
all by now seen images of people
kneeling practically genuflecting in
service of the new gods are there so
many new converts in the world truly as
the berkeley professor says in his
letter it's hard to know what kneeling
means when you have to kneel to keep
your job Wow
yeah racism of the gaps is right on the
money that's what we're seeing and this
actually dovetails very well with what I
think the secondary meaning of that that
video that we saw is so I would like to
to back us up slightly and put something
on the table so late last night as I was
trying to get one of our cats to come in
I went for a walk with the dog and I was
listening to Sam Harris most recent
podcast episode on the meaning of this
moment and there was a lot in it it's
really well done and I recommend it the
purpose of the of the piece is largely
to do something that I've advocated many
times I've said in order to have in
order to make
compassionate policy you have to do a
dispassionate analysis right it feels
counterintuitive but anyway he does a
very good job of going through these
statistics that accompany use of lethal
force by police and what it has to say
about the presence or absence of racism
and it's really it's remarkably careful
but the place he starts is someplace
that I think a lot of us have landed in
independently he alleges that we are
actually losing our minds and that this
has something to do with the Internet
and we've talked about this and anyway I
think I think all people who are trying
to grapple with the meaning of the
moment are landing on this formulation
but the question is okay we're losing
our minds but can we say anything more
about it and the reason that that video
of that apparently peaceful protests are
being hauled off I mean hauled out of a
crowd specifically because he's the one
talking that really looks like an
egregious violation of his First
Amendment rights and it's not the only
video that looks like this but what
struck me most was that I had not seen
them right I came to that video because
Sam Harris said something on his Twitter
feed about what is the meaning of these
videos in which apparently peaceful
protesters are addressed by the police
and I thought I haven't seen those
videos I've seen videos in which the
police are very aggressive but I also
know that the protesters are being very
aggressive what's he talking about
and so I went looking and I found videos
on Camille Foster's Twitter feed and I
looked at them and they were exactly as
described and I thought this is so
relevant at this moment that the fact
that I am not running into it is telling
us something and I think what it's
telling us is that Twitter's algorithm
whatever it is thinks I'm a conservative
because I say a lot of things about what
isn't right over on the left and it has
misunderstood me and also it thinks that
if you're conservative which you're not
but that if you were a conservative you
would be uninterested in seeing things
that confound your current views right
or maybe even to say that it thinks is
the mistake because what it is doing I
would suggest is it is simply fee
people that which confirms what they
already believe and so here's my very
simple contention about some large
fraction of what is taking place at the
moment
everybody is plugged into an apparatus
that is sitting in between us the way
conversation used to and what it is
doing is it is feeding us things that
confirm what we actually believe much of
which is real but that in effect people
smart scientific people who know very
well that the right way to think
carefully is to be falsification astute
for things that disconfirm your beliefs
are being fed and overwhelmingly
verification aestethic and that is
causing everybody to be dead sure they
know what's going on when very few of us
have any clue and one thing that is so
different about this moment than the
moment of 20 years ago or 40 years ago
is that we had editors and people have
complained about editors and the move
towards social media is seen by some as
a populist revolution in which anyone
can have voice but if you want to watch
fox news and also want to watch CNN you
know something about the editorial
biases of those networks and you can
choose to watch both and you know that
you are going to get still skewed still
edited still presumably biased but
versions of the biases and edits of
those perspective networks whereas on
Twitter if you follow a wide variety of
people as you and I do you follow I
follow Camille Foster and Sam Harris and
boy there's so many other people who
once you found this I went looking what
there are many people who I follow and I
don't follow thousands of people
specifically so that I can see what
these people are saying there are many
people whom you and I follow who have
been posting these videos and neither of
us were seeing them that tells us that
this is not the same as being able to go
and decide I'm going to read the New
York Times and I'm going to read The
Wall Street Journal I'm going to watch
CNN and I'm going to watch Fox it's not
the same thing we are we have had our
choice taken away but we have we are
being given the appearance the
we have more choice than ever we have
the sense that we are correcting for
this but you have no idea how quickly
you have to swim upstream to counteract
the algorithm and so this is having an
absolutely the wildering effect on us I
think and for me the iconic instance of
this is Dave Chappelle's new video right
so I have not seen it yet so it's titled
846 that 8 minutes and 46 seconds is
what Derrick Chauvin Snee spent on on
George Floyd's neck and this piece is
not really a comedy piece and you know
Chappelle talks about that and I must
say I know you share my feelings about
this but I think Chappelle is he's a
he's a genius and his genius extends to
many different things he's figured out a
way to to be authentic but to look
through the eyes of someone else and
allow them to see the authenticity of
something that they are predisposed not
to see so anyway there's no shortage of
love and gratitude for what he's
delivered this piece that he's put out
very popular piece retweeted by Joe
Rogan very enthusiastically Barry Weiss
I think who is punishing us for
something I don't know what but in any
case the the Chappelle piece is wrong
and it's wrong completely authentically
and so anyway in some sense no you're
speaking there presumably many of the
people watching have seen it or you know
you you guys have the luxury of stepping
aside and watching and I don't at the
moment yeah what what is wrong about it
what I don't I don't I'm asking that up
because I've seen it and don't see
anything wrong but because I actually
don't know what's in it what's wrong
with it is that it doesn't take into
account what sam harris painstakingly
goes through which is that our
intuitions about what is going on have
very little to do with what the data
suggests is going on and so the point is
now I want to be very careful that
people do not misinterpret what I'm
saying I think there's something very
real about this moment and this protest
and one of the things is driving me
crazy is that the message is so wrong
the focus is so wrong that we do not
understand that the tremendous
frustration that is boiling over in our
streets and frankly threatening the
Republic and maybe more that that
frustration is simply being delivered
with a false set of labels and so we
don't even know how to interpret it
so my point to you is that Chapelle
looks at the protests and he says
effectively you're goddamn right right
of course people are angry of course
they're angry and he talks about some of
these cases that we've seen on video
that just seems so upsetting right but
the problem is that those cases are at
best anecdotes and of course even if
those cases are exactly what we think
they are the fact that those cases may
not be disproportionate suggests that
race may not be playing the role that we
think it's playing and does that mean
that black people are not perceiving
some sort of substantial obstacle that
is blocking progress that I would argue
has stalled progress no they are
detecting something and when you see
somebody do something egregious on
videotape and you feel this force
holding you back and you put two and two
together and you say those two things
are the same thing right you may not be
right it may be that those things have
nothing to do with each other and as I
have said before the visceral anecdote
will always be more powerful than the
dispassionate statistic right and if we
can take a non-racial example I said in
my talk how the magic trick is done that
a woman who's walking down the street
who takes some look that I give her to
be full of some kind of meaning that she
finds creepy doesn't know whether it was
actually a creepy look or am I just
awkward and I gave the guy who walked
down the street next to her the same
weird look right you can't tell if all
you have is an edit and so what we have
is in an hair
leigh-anne inherently biased set it is
much more interesting in some sense when
the thing matches some narrative about
some very powerful force of racism that
is alive and well in the US and you know
what there is a force of racism that is
alive and well in the US but it's small
right most people are not encountering
it every day the number of you know one
of the things that Sam reveals is that
actually in 2019 the number of police
shootings was at an all-time low
the number of killings by police in Los
Angeles in 2019 was at an all-time low
and so there's something there's some
question about are we moving in the
right direction are these things
racially biased these are questions that
are addressed by tools that we know now
here's the crazy thing what did we see
this last week those very tools are
under attack shut down stem Y is shut
down stem marching with some cartoonish
presentation of the role racism is
playing in America because if you have
the tools then you can test the claim so
those who are advancing false claims
have an interest in shutting down those
tools shutting down any claim that has
been demonstrated with them any doubt
that has been established and so well
this emerges in part I don't have the
quote I will I will paraphrase it and
hopefully I don't butcher it but the the
Audrey Lorde quotation from I think it
will have been the 1970s in which she
says you don't you can't tear down the
Masters house with the Masters tools you
know which is a ridiculous and
disempowering message actually as as so
much of the material in the message
income coming across the transom from
these these movements these so-called
anti-racist movements are often actually
disempowering for exactly the
populations whom they are purporting to
try to raise up right and to the extent
that so my claim about Chappell would be
that he is he would present the story as
it really is
if he could see it but he is also
subject to a world of algorithms that
have categorized him some way and so
somehow I think he's missed the point
but he's still Dave Chappelle so in some
sense as much as I hate to see him
present something that I think is
incorrect it's also hopeful because
being Dave Chappelle he's capable of
seeing it right and so what would be
amazing is if there was a dialogue in
which the point was okay Dave we heard
what you have to say here's the
counterpoint that would be a remarkable
dialogue yeah no it certainly would and
this is gonna seem wrong but I feel like
responding with an anecdote but I think
that the point here is that here's
here's one of my interactions with the
police from when I was in high school in
the would have been the mid to late 80s
87 maybe when I was newly driving and my
point here is going to be I got to see I
got to see firsthand that there was
disparity at least for a couple of
police officers in LA in the 80s between
how they treated a black person versus
versus a bunch of white people and and
it stuck with me and this is you know
this has been one of the things that I
have I've told you I've only said it
publicly once actually before now but my
point ultimately is things have gotten a
lot better since then and the way to
assess that claim is through the
statistics the very statistics that you
say that Sam Harris was going through in
his most recent podcast so it's you know
it's just it's a short little anecdote
I'm I'm driving in my ten-year-old car
on Sunset Boulevard on the curvy part of
Sunset Boulevard in West LA where it's
the speed limit is 35 but if you enjoy
driving and if you're breaking the law
you might go 50 and I come around a
curve and someone else is doing the same
thing it's a little the day and it's the
only time this ever happened pretty
quickly four of us in a pack of cars are
driving stupidly fast on sunset and we
come around one curve and there's a cop
waiting his cops often were you know in
a car turns out a siren pulls out behind
us you know directs us into the next
into the next side street and pulls us
all over as he should have we were being
a responsible no none of us knew each
other we just spontaneous street racing
taking his street racing right and none
of us knew each other none of us were
driving fancier expensive cars and none
of us knew until the moment that he
forced us all over as he should have
done and it was a a white cop with a
white guy who the white cop sitting next
to him got out of the car and he ordered
all of us out of the car barking equally
at each of us and we got out and I was
the only person in my car and I'm white
and there were a couple of people on
each of two of the other cars and they
were white and the fourth car had a
young black man it and the cop proceeded
to speak very gently and politely to me
and to the other white people and the
other cars and quite differently quite
aggressively at quite quite a lot of
volume to this young black man and the
fact is in this case we had all been
behaving exactly the same way we were
all kiltie of exactly the same crime
right and as far as I can tell the
outcome of this is that he led us all
off with warning so the formal legal
outcome was it was equivalent for
everyone but the fact is that one of
four items in this case one of four
drivers doing exactly the same thing got
singled out for treatment on the basis
of what there was only one thing that I
could see that was different about him
and it was his skin colour that would
have been I think 1986 1987 and it that
was an anecdote and I had no access to
the statistics at that time but I
understood in my gut that there was
something about driving while black that
was real that would never be true for me
question is to what extent have police
improved and has it become ever less
acceptable to be racist in Americans
in the years since then yes and so it
you know I think driving while black
registered with a lot of us we got it
then there was a different experience
and that this was something so
universally shared by black people that
even though white people were unlikely
to encounter it directly we inferred
that something there was something we
could not see a force we could not see
this is exactly the opposite of what
will happen in a world where the
algorithms feed you that which you
expect or want to hear and so we are now
watching a movement that and I saw a
remarkable footage of the protests in
Paris this is spreading this is now a
global phenomenon that is ostensibly
reacting to a systematic pattern of
lethal violence that is racially
motivated amongst police that is not
reflected in the data right that is a
frightening prospect for two reasons one
so can you spell that out a little bit
more I haven't seen what's going on in
Paris I'd like to know exactly what I'd
like you to just maybe even just say
that in different words I think what I
think is taking place is that there is
something deeply wrong you can feel it
in this Dave Chappelle piece right Dave
Chappelle has had it he is sick and
tired of being told there isn't a
problem and he has landed in the wrong
spot because the message is so
overwhelming that you can see the
problem in lethal violence by white cops
against black citizens right that he is
now he just simply didn't check it he
didn't go falsification astray if he had
what he would find is that the data do
not reflect this pattern that it is true
that blacks are disproportionately
killed by cops but not
disproportionately relative to their
disproportionate share of crime now the
discussion I want to have is what is
that disparity in crime about and I
think a lot of people including a lot of
frankly sophisticated white thinkers
believe that this has something to do
with black people being different
I don't believe that that's where this
is coming from so what I said on Twitter
the other day was that this patterns
that we are seeing have very little to
do with modern racism and have a lot to
do with past racism and that this is
different for two populations as I've
said elsewhere black population and the
Indian population in the u.s. have a
special situation other populations deal
with racism there's a level of ambient
racism it doesn't prevent them from
succeeding these two populations have a
special obstacle that they face and so
what we are seeing and distinct from one
another quite distinct but they share a
feature right which is both of these
cases there was a systematic effort to
erase the on board culture to neutralize
the on board culture because that on
board culture was dangerous to the role
that white people that European people
needed these populations to to play so
so just at the most at the most surface
level do the explicit taking of Native
American children and putting them into
white schools basically re educating
them so they would forget anything that
they had known in their home culture and
putting newly enslaved Africans who had
been brought over obviously against
their will into groups of people with
whom they did not share a culture or a
language so that they could not
communicate and they they could not
effectively keep almost anything the
culture from which they've been stolen
right the breaking apart of families
right the mixing of people who were from
different had different traditions to
begin with so that everything starts out
as a pidgin and then becomes a Creole
but it's not it's nobody's original
culture no one's saying says that
historic racism hasn't been a remarkable
force throughout throughout the 15 16 17
18 19 century but it's not even this is
racism with a special mechanism right
this special mechanism takes the
cultural program that people have a
disrupts the connection with the thing
to which it's evolved so in some sense
black people and Indians were removed
from what you and I would technically
call the
an environment of evolutionary
adaptiveness for their culture right so
your culture matches your environment
you remove people from their environment
either by transporting them across an
ocean in a ship or by putting them on a
reservation and taking them off their
ancestral lands right already they have
a new problem
right their culture is not adapted to
the place they've just landed and then
you go through systematic process of
disrupting that culture further in order
to make people compliant and docile and
unable to resist and all of those things
and then something happens there's an
awakening this is wrong maybe you stop
doing it but you don't fix the problem
right and so anyway I believe that those
things echo through to this moment in a
most profound way and that it is
resulting in the detection in these
populations that something is wrong it's
no secret in these populations that
something is very secret is very
seriously wrong mm-hmm
but the question is what do you say if
you if the problem is subtle right if
the problem is one of somebody busted my
software and then they loaded some
software that works somewhat for me but
it also works for them right and now I
have a problem most people don't have
because I have to disentangle those two
forces right that's so you're talking
about human soft right now oh yeah right
okay yeah I'd be back up and make that
super clear because I was thinking
computers until the end of that sentence
no no yeah yeah I mean computers were
very rare until the 20th century that's
how I understand it yeah but in any case
so there is a real problem but I think
the point I'm getting at is it's not
that it isn't a serious problem it's
every bit as serious as people perceive
but it isn't housed in these simple
things what's the problem with being
black it's that you know you're in
danger of being slaughtered on any given
day by a police officer no for one thing
we can check that we can check it with
the tools of stem right why are we
shutting down stem because you can check
it with the tools of stem and and
because there's only one explanation
allowed because we have compelled speech
which moves us into compelled thought
right and you must destroy stem in order
to not have people say actually there
are a lot of possible explanations let's
figure out which one is true let's be
yep so so that that raises the question
then of what is taking place so the the
tough thing I think if you're being fed
some analog of what I'm seeing right the
temptation is just to say well okay
this movement is phony the claims are
wrong
this is jeopardizing the Republic let's
just shut it down right and there's no
awareness that the claims are wrong in
my opinion
the named movements that are at the head
of this thing are illegitimate they are
pushing a phony story and they are
pushing the most absurd remedies I can
imagine I mean the idea that we are
talking about abolishing the police and
you've got maybe this is where you're
going but you've got a video that you're
gonna have Zach show with another one of
these proposed remedies oh we can we can
go with a number of these things maybe
we should in fact hey Zach can you put
up the New York Times piece here so
first of all we have been in endless
arguments we hear people say defund the
police abolish the police hold on a
second and we are always when we say
abolish the police do you realize that
there's not a neighborhood in America
where that would not be a catastrophe no
matter how bad your police are there's
no place where removing them would be a
net gain for the people who live there
and then we're told so actually I've
come up with a name for this that Steve
as recline off' occation of language
right so Ezra Klein takes something like
kill all men and he says well that's not
really what they mean so in this case
we've got you know there's always a
police and then he you know somebody's
gonna come in and they're gonna as
recline of [ __ ] the thing up and tell us
that that doesn't mean abolish the
police that it means something else like
reform them or you know demilitarized
them or something like that but then we
find out in the New York Times actually
lo and behold we were right all along
okay you can now put it up here we go
okay yes we literally mean abolish the
police okay I knew that you knew that
because we've actually had the police
abolished on us
in the New York Times under its new
leadership has gone in the head and
given us the evidence that we were
looking for thank you
well I mean you know in a sense they
have done us a service because they've
you know and this is one of the
arguments that those of us who are
fiercely in favor of maintaining free
speech even for abhorrent perspectives
have said which is when somebody is
advancing something truly awful you want
to hear what they have to say you don't
want to shut it down because that
actually prevents us from being fully
horrified so this article in The New
York Times actually says look we're
talking about literally about from the
police they can't be reformed it doesn't
anywhere mention the net effect question
well what they proposed with regard to
law and order instead oh well they have
lots of lovely proposals but my point is
were this the least bit reasonable then
the point is we are going to provide
this mechanism that makes the police
unnecessary and then we're going to
abolish the police that's not the point
somehow these people are they're so
confused or so disingenuous that they
are actually advocating we abolish the
police first right this is madness this
could not possibly be a dumber idea and
you and I have seen this in person we
have had the police withdrawn from a
riot where they were shouting my name
and they were apparently hunting for me
one car to the next and the police were
withdrawn from the situation we saw
people inside of 24 hours of that order
battered by student protesters student
on student violence with weapons for the
crime of disagreeing we saw the whole
thing unfold and the fact is it's
happening again it's happening in the
center of Seattle and you know I mean on
the one hand I'm kind of pissed off
because I feel like we lived it so that
other people don't have to and yet we're
doing it again but all right second
degree this stuff that's going on in
Seattle is squarely and governor
Inslee's Court like that goes on his
ledger because he did nothing when
Evergreen happened and he's doing
nothing now he didn't even mention
when Evergreen happened he went radio
silent and was radio silent I believe
for years never mentioned evergreens was
happening in his office we went to his
office with your students asked for an
audience got instead two of his two of
his aides it's on civil rights and it's
on higher ed yeah
spent two hours talking to them we're
told that we get a response no response
no response notice never responded and
then when he was asked about somehow
he's still the governor of Washington
anyway he was asked about the the
Capitol Hill autonomous zone in Seattle
and he responded that he didn't know
about it right which is an amazingly
amazing claim but anyway we should talk
about what the Capitol Hill autonomous
zone actually means but let's just say
that at the very least there's a battle
over interpretation you've got lots of
people claiming that the autonomous zone
is is chaos it's Anarchy run amok is
anarchy well and that it's chaos and
then you have other people claiming that
it's being miss portrayed and it's
actually a lovely place and it's
demonstrating everything it needs to
demonstrate basically the police shut
down their precinct and walked away you
could see this as it was happening I
didn't know what the hell was going on I
was watching aerial footage of the
police taking their computers and things
out of this building said what are they
about to do but all right yeah exactly
you show us that video from the no the
other one who's kind of fit with it I
guess
like me when I walk around anywhere I
sweat like I have a glandular problem
it's a horrifying condition I promise
you nevertheless so this is where we are
if you might recall again I'll tell the
story I tell remind you we were standing
right over here by this [ __ ] Trump sign
when they threw the [ __ ] relays at us
and that was a [ __ ] thing and so here
it is this is just another wall of our
art our our expression of our feelings
all right so that remarkable piece of
video I mean it starts out with him
showing that in the Capitol Hill
autonomous zone they should work the
arts and so there was a beautiful mural
there I noticed a lot of sentiments were
clearly expressed repeated for a greater
artistic expression
shoot shoot all of the police did it say
that was good
[ __ ] 12 this is when I have can you
imagine how screwed we'd be if they got
rid of 12 I mean we're already in an
awkward relationship with 13 they're
gonna get rid of 12 now all right
by the way [ __ ] 12 is about what is it
it's the letters of the alphabet 12 is
yes 13 12 is a cab and 12 is the police
so in any case the the person shooting
this this mural is obviously relieved of
his camera at which point he suddenly
remembers that law and order heck
actually has a positive effect as well
as a negative one so that's that's a
remarkable thing but lots of things are
going on in the Capitol Hill autonomous
zone including apparently extortion from
the business owners they're being forced
to tie the effectively pay protection to
have their businesses not damaged but
let's talk about the larger issue okay
because what's really going on here I
think now we don't know why it is that
the police walked away from this
neighborhood when they did but it was
clearly planned mm-hm
my guess would be that they walked away
in hopes that the protesters would do
would run amok and that that would
therefore explain to the world why the
police need
to crack down I think the the protesters
realized that they had an opportunity on
their hands and that opportunity
involved if they can just restrain their
impulses in this instance and if they
can behave themselves it will
demonstrate to the world that they are
correct that you can just remove the
police and everything will be fine and
then suddenly that plan will start
spreading at which point absolute mayhem
is going to break out now they're not
doing a great job because of course the
problem with trying to maintain your
discipline when the police have been
withdrawn is that it creates a power
vacuum and bad people will take
advantage of a power vacuum so what we
have is R as Simone having come in and
he is patrolling the thing with weapons
and harassing people and so it's
becoming exactly like evergreen I mean
it's really evergreen 2.0 at greater
scale with worse weapons and you know
I'd still say I'm I'm a little bit
impressed that it hasn't broken down
worse faster but this is really where we
are we're in a battle over
interpretations of what is taking place
if they can maintain message discipline
so that the world sees basically a you
know a kumbaya phenomenon going on there
the world will misunderstand and may
attempt to duplicate the success that is
demonstrated in the Capitol Hill
autonomous zone elsewhere and it is
other autonomous zones are now being set
up
I believe in Portland one is being set
up and actually let's just cut to the
chase what is this all really about so
I'm going to make a claim my claim is
going to be and I said this back when
evergreen happened that the real plan
actually let me step back this is two
things that have come together okay this
movement that we are seeing is two
things come together one of them is
occupied 2.0 and although we
participated in occupy occupy 2.0 I
don't mean anything that I would
remotely sign on to okay occupy started
out as a complaint about the bias in our
system started out as a complaint about
two big
to fail which was used as an excuse to
bail out the people who had caused the
problem
you know the tarp program etc but it
morphed into an anarchist nightmare
it became foolish it lost its way this
is now the 2.0 version of that anarchist
nightmare and it is fused together with
black lives matter black lives matter
which is according to its slogan a good
match for something important black
lives are undervalued and I believe that
is true we can see that based on the
failure to invests in black communities
but these two things have come together
an economic complaint about a rigged
system that morphed into an anarchist
nightmare and an actual complaint about
real bias that is hard to put your
finger on against black people that has
now become an excuse for all sorts of
other things and the plan that is
unfolding is actually this reparations
at all times in every venue right every
interaction is going to have a
reparation in it and the reparation is
first and foremost about blacks but it's
really about the intersectional the you
will receive reparations on the basis of
where you fall intersectionally and as
you have pointed out there are very real
trans people who face very real
obstacles in life but trans is the one
place where you can opt into
intersectional points so you have this
movement proposing reparations
everywhere and the reparations
everywhere is a very frightening
prospect because a you can't actual
reparations program which I wouldn't
favor but nonetheless is at least a
coherent proposal that would be done
with society deciding to take resources
and distribute them in a particular way
if it happens in every interaction it is
the absolute destruction of meritocracy
so let's take a look at that other end
of relationship of everything it's the
it's the inversion of decency it is just
so let's let's see that other video ok I
want you to find by the end by the time
leave this autonomous cell I want you to
give $10 to one african-american person
from this autonomous zone and if you
find that's difficult if you find this
hard for you to give $10 to people of
color to black people especially you
have to think really critically about in
the future are you gonna actually give
up power and land and capital when you
have it if you're if you have a hard
time giving up $10 you guys think about
are you really down with this struggle
are you really down with the movement
because if that is a challenge for you
then I'm unsure if you're in the right
place so fine an african-american person
the white people I see you I see every
single one of you and I remember your
faces you find that african-american
person and you give them $10 cash app
then month ten dollars in your pocket
that's my challenge to you do it all
right so that video contains a lot one
thing is the reaction of people when
they are actually asked to hand over
money individually is much less
enthusiastic when then when they are
trying to force other people to do it so
that's not surprising at all from a game
theoretic perspective but I think we
really need to just understand that the
proposals are so insane so dangerous
that we have to not take them seriously
we have to understand that even if the
movement is motivated by actual
frustration about really really
important things that the presentation
is basically threatening to scuttle the
entire operation for no reason so
imagine for a second what the world
would look like if if this movement
succeeds in advancing its vision what
does law-and-order look like going
forward under
the you know the world after the police
have been disbanded can you show the
proposals the the demands that were
issued from the Capitol Hill autonomous
zone I sent it to you well we can talk
about what they were so the demands the
long list of demands you know remove
signature move long list of demands and
then I don't I haven't seen this list
yet but often at the top of the list is
a demand to be able to take as many much
time as you want to make further demands
yes the the wish to I want as many
wishes as I can have right right I'm not
sure if that one is in here or not they
may have just forgotten it but but they
reserve the right well sure it's such a
diminutive couch I'm sure um okay but on
this list yeah you can put it up so
scroll down look and if you're the top
of the list boy I can't can you get on
the other screen so I can read just the
okay yeah okay so it says given the
historical moment we will begin with our
demands pertaining to the justice system
the Seattle Police Department
and attached court system are beyond
reform we do not request reform we
demand abolition most of the police and
the court system it's literally both law
and order that they demand abolitionists
believe me it is both law and order as
they also demand further down if you
scroll down there's a highlight oh
there's the highlight we demand retrial
of all people of color currently serving
a prison sentence for violent crime by a
jury of their peers in their community
so they would like to retry all people
of color yes there so this is the first
time I'm seeing this are they demanding
a retrial for people of color who were
serving sentences for nonviolent crime
or just those who were serving sentences
for violent crime that's an
extraordinary demand right there it
stands alone without a demand for
retrial of people who actually were
found guilty of committing non-violent
crime
if I remember correctly they delayed
offenses yeah they demanded a certain
number of people be just simply released
which you know in the case of marijuana
nonviolent marijuana offenses I'd be all
for that but but in any case they are
proposing oh I mean imagine how this
would look
okay you start retrying people of color
who are currently serving a prison
sentence for violent crime right
how fair do we think these trials would
be they have no chance of being fair
right now well they have no chance of
being fair right now they're certainly
going to be a bias in favor of assuming
that there was so much bias in the first
trial that it should probably be
overturned right but also you know they
effectively I mean elsewhere I've seen
just the advocacy for the complete
ablution abolition of the prison system
so we're talking about a turning a lot
of very dangerous people is actually
dangerous people who in many cases may
be psychopathic may not be in any way
recoverable right so at the same time
you're talking about eliminating the
police so the mechanism that would
disincentivize those people from
harassing murdering everybody you know
anybody who resists but they also might
generate themselves effectively an army
in other words given the tenor of the
moment I would imagine that your chances
of being exonerated in a retrial would
have a lot to do with whether or not you
said the right kinds of things about the
movement and it's its necessity so ok
you can take that you can take that down
now Zak ok so anyway the basic point I
guess is the proposals are not if they
were advanced in a brainstorming session
about how civilization might be remade
they would be immediately shot down on
the basis that they are not tenable and
the people who advanced such terrible
dangerous ideas would lose credibility
in in in an honest brainstorming session
about civilization and the fact that we
don't have the power to do that has to
do only with the social incentives
surrounding this moment right anything
that points in one direction is
considered not only legitimate but
obvious and important and anything that
goes in the other direction is presumed
to be
null and void and the result of pure
racism it's such a simple game
so obviously game upon and yet those of
us who are saying just that are because
we are all within this game that we
never wanted to play so easily accused
of by simply saying that we must be
doing so by reason of racism all you
have to do is cloak something in the
language of black lives matter or shut
down stem or whatever it is whatever the
tagline is at the moment and you can get
away with almost anything else you can
slip in almost anything else as long as
it fits generally under that guise and
anything that runs counter you you are
not allowed to investigate to think
about to consider so then the question
is I find us in a very dangerous
predicament which is ok we're beginning
to figure out we're beginning to be able
to discuss just how preposterous the
movement is which does not mean that the
fuel that is driving it isn't based on
something very important all right the
frustration about an economic system
that is rigged against many people
that's rated against Millennials through
debt it's rigged against certain
populations based on where you where you
are born and grow up what kind of
schools are there the frustration is
real it is bewildering to everybody
either you it seems to be that either
you land on the I'm in favor of these
protests side and therefore I accept
their discussion of what has taken place
and what should happen now or I reject
these protests and I don't believe that
this is unfair I believe civilization is
pretty fair and I'm not listening the
right position is in the space that has
not existed until now or has struggled
to exist and so far failed to get a
foothold which is how can we discuss the
actual problem without embracing this
lunacy and it is lunacy the idea of
removing the police is that is basically
a gun to the head of the Republic
so I think Sam did an excellent job of
extending the Overton Window
statistically speaking so that we can
look at the claim of lethal police
violence and whether or not it appears
to be racially motivated Eric put out a
very interesting essay at the beginning
of his most recent portal I haven't
listened to the whole thing so I can't
recommend the whole episode yet because
I never do that if I haven't listened
but but anyway the essay at the
beginning is quite excellent yeah
it's about something he talked about
when he was on the Dark Horse podcast
several days ago the culture of
meritocracy inside the black community
which is a very interesting topic these
are four rays into the no man's land
that exists between the two wrong
perspectives civilization is fair and
civilization is so biased that we have
to pull the plug on it right the forays
are really important we have to figure
out how to discuss these things we have
to figure out how to protect people who
do discuss these things even when
they're wrong they have to be protected
so that they have the ability to explore
without being immediately blown up for
making an error right and I think the
iconic example is Dave Chappelle I mean
I sort of feel like it's great that an
honest broker who does get the
frustration clearly right he clearly
gets the real problem and who has gained
the trust of so many people if he can be
compelled that actually there is a way
that this story does add up that isn't
one of these two other versions that
will be that will be a huge gain for all
of us yeah yeah well we're at about an
hour about an hour we're at four now I
think that's where we're at for now okay
so we wanted to
so it'd make a couple of say couple of
things about changes that are afoot we
are going to as usual read answer super
check questions that came in this time
on the YouTube live stream and also
those that come in on the following one
and the Q&A that we will do starting in
about 15 minutes we have also added to
my patreon a couple of Tears such that
we are trying to basically establish a
way to show support to have membership
in the Dark Horse live streams so and we
haven't posted this on yours yet but we
will do so that at the $5 a month level
you will have access to a private live
stream that we will do in which in which
we answer questions that are not
otherwise out there and at the $11 a
month or more level you will have
priority asking such questions that
later then answer and we'll do these
once a month
private live streams to people who are
interested in hearing more from us all
right I have one more thing and then we
will take our break and return to do the
QA the one more thing is I want to make
perfectly clear a Dave Chappelle you'd
be absolutely welcome to come talk to us
about this the second thing is Dave
Chappelle I think you've got this one
somewhat wrong but that doesn't make me
right I'd be equally up to have you
compel me that I've got it wrong so one
way or the other I think the important
thing is that the discussion happened
all right everybody we will see you in
about 15 minutes in the meantime be well
you